hey what is up guys I'm Kip EHD here and
I wasn't originally going to make a
video about this
in fact I'm working on some other things
at the moment but I asked on Twitter if
you guys cared about this and a lot of
you guys said yes a lot of you guys were
interested in this particular thing
because of what I tweeted about so I'm
going to talk about Motorola slash
Google revealed something today that
they've been working on project ara
which is yet another concept for a
modular smartphone sounds familiar right
we've seen this before if you remember
the phone blocks explain video I did not
too long ago if you didn't get to catch
that that will be the first link right
below that like button but the thing is
phone blocks
didn't come from a large manufacturer
phone blocks did not come from a big
company looking to actually change the
game it came from a smaller youtube
video maker who was just looking to
spread the idea about something he
believed in today Motorola revealed that
they've been working on this are a
concept for a modular smartphone for
more than a year now so foam blocks came
out of the blue two months ago and
project ara has apparently been worked
on for more than a year now so we're
supposed to believe that these two had
absolutely nothing to do with each other
until recently when they got together
and said alright let's do this let's
make this a thing we have the same idea
let's just collaborate and make this
happen and so now there's a Motorola
blog post about it there's an updated
phonebloks website and there's a new
phonebloks video on youtube all those
links are below
they actually have some updated visuals
now it is entirely possible that Google
and Motorola and Dave from phonebloks
have been working together for way
longer than they tell us and it is
possible that the phonebloks concept was
a guerilla marketing campaign or an
experiment from Motorola to see if
people were actually interested in this
and now that it's gone super viral
they're publicizing their plans to make
it real it's all possible but I'm just
going to go with what they're saying I'm
going to believe for a second that
everything that they're telling us is
true and that everything that they're
coming out with is indeed a genuinely
new idea that they're actually
collaborating I believe for a minute
that this is an amazing coincidence that
is just now gaining a full head of steam
on the day that the phonebloks
thunderclap was scheduled to happen but
now I'm interested I am much more
interested than I was before see when I
first did that phonebloks explained
video
talked about how that idea was
essentially pretty unrealistic it seemed
unfeasible unreasonable the whole
concept it had very few technical
details at all involved in that videos
mostly a marketing campaign and a lot of
people agree that it didn't seem very
likely to happen at all but how is Aurra
different from phonebloks well on the
surface it's not it's the same concept
it's a slightly better looking design
obviously a little bit more convincing
that you would carry a phone that looks
like that but the idea is the same the
biggest change here and the reason why
it's making headlines again is the fact
that Motorola and Google are now behind
this some thinking this is lining up to
be either a huge success or a huge
failure this has been according to the
blogpost under wraps and being worked on
by Google and Motorola for over a year
now which means if Google's engineering
power and their finances are actually
putting effort into this and research
and development into making an idea like
this actually happen then they have
plans to change the game
it sounds like they really want this to
be a huge success and I definitely know
what I hope that it turns out to be if
this turns out to be a huge success it's
going to be because Google and Motorola
actually care about fundamentally
changing the way we see and use our
smartphones and that's huge that's
disruptive that's bold and that's also
dangerous and very risky but it's
awesome but at the same time if this
fails it's because Google and Motorola
tried to suddenly fundamentally change
the way we think about smartphones and
the world wasn't ready and it was
technically infeasible and it just
didn't come together in time and it was
very risky and dangerous and that's why
it would end up not working so for this
I think we should consider other
products like Google glass and
smartwatches
and even the original first iPhone where
they're the first two they're form
factor they're the first to do what they
do and it might not seem like modular
smartphones are an entirely new form
factor but they definitely are and they
are something that's never been done
before and something that's never been
done before always starts off in a very
expensive and very controversial way so
I say let's give it a chance let's see
how serious they are and who knows maybe
with all the engineering genius and
funding from Google maybe something like
this will actually become a reality and
even if this does fail it's nice to see
someone legitimately trying to innovate
and
the game rather than just playing it too
safe and who knows it might pave the way
for other manufacturers to continue to
try to change the game in this way and
do unique modular things like this I was
also thinking in a couple of years it
might be kind of funny to see a
commercial for like the ultimate foam
box experience where they fuse all the
foam blocks together and make it nice
and small and compact seems like we'd be
going forwards and then backwards there
but whatever who knows so what do you
think is it possible to own the same
smartphone fundamentally for like a
couple of years maybe more than the
usual two years even if you are
replacing a whole bunch of the parts are
you in are you into this idea I want to
believe like I want to be convinced but
they have a lot of convincing to do
either way thanks for watching this
quick video let me know what your
thoughts are below and I will talk to
you guys in that comment section and of
course in the very next video
thanks for watching guys peace
you